foreign
[Music]
ER engineer here at Google Cloud welcome
back to the technical series for
startups where we're creating a series
of videos for technical enablement for
startups to start build and grow their
businesses successfully and sustainably
on Google Cloud we've been on an
absolutely amazing journey with you in
this build Series where we have covered
various topics from infrastructure data
analytics to machine learning just last
video we did a deep dive on the security
Command Center and now that you have an
understanding of how you can build using
our services on Google cloud in this
video we'll look at how you can
effectively manage your environment with
all these services using Cloud task and
Cloud scheduler I'll be covering an
overview of cloud tasks and Cloud
scheduler on how it works its use cases
as well as how we can combine it
together we'll then wrap up with some of
our customers success case studies on
how they're using the services on Google
Cloud today and without further Ado
let's get started to learn more about
Cloud task and Cloud scheduler as we
move our monolithic application to
microservices that are easy to build
maintain and upgrade we often find
ourselves having to manage various
components of our architecture from high
volumes of notification data ingestion
to trigger workloads we should be able
to have a service where we can offload
the work to the background one that you
can organize and control for quicker
response times and smoother interactions
across services to help you focus on
what truly matters for your business
instead of having to worry about all
these background tasks
how we can do this is with services such
as Cloud tasks where you can easily
create new queues and offload any
asynchronous tasks giving you a
distributed task use that you can
integrate with any of your application
ask our pieces of work that you can
perform independently outside of your
main application workflow and this
offloaded tasks are added to a new queue
until it successfully executed this
could be as simple as executing tasks
asynchronously for new user
registrations having to use a complete a
certain task and then finally sending a
welcome email
diving into some of the benefits how
cloudcast can help you with is for long
running processes it can often tie up
some of your high performance computing
power affecting your application's
performance with Cloud tasks tasks are
executed asynchronously helping to
reduce latency and by utilizing
resources more effectively this can also
help to reduce costs in the long run
Club tasks can also help with timeouts
and field requests by configuring retry
parameters which are important for
handling transient failures it also has
a reliable delivery by handling testing
duplication and at least once delivery
also for release and Incident Management
you can control the execution with rate
limiting by setting the rate at which
tasks are dispatch the maximum number of
attempts and the minimum amount of time
to wait between the test if you have any
resource capacity issues Cloud tasks can
also control the delivery flow rates for
you to meet your quotas
it is scalable and can be managed with
popular Cayenne libraries from your
choice you can enqueue tasks using the
rest API from any language and anywhere
your tasks can be executed on the app
engine or any HTTP endpoint that can
securely reach Google's kubernetes
engine compute engine and Cloud right or
on-premises systems using industry
standard authentication with easy to
integrate apis cloudpets can be a great
way for you to simplify your
architecture you simply add tasks to the
queue and cloudcast handles the rest
Cloud task also uses identity and access
management for Access Control where it's
configured at both a project and queue
level for instance you can grant access
with limited capabilities to create and
add task to queue but not to give you a
queue you can also switch on and off
Cloud logging for a queues and to ensure
that you are properly monitoring your
Cloud test cubes to detect abnormal
behavior we have various predefined task
metrics like number of tasks in EQ API
calls task tabs and delays for you to
monitor
and here are some scenarios you can use
cloud passport as a request buffer where
you can manage resource consumption
system maintenance or inter-service
communication
this would be useful for constrained
resources in terms of cost or quarter
limits like bigquery slot quotas or even
on-premises databases where it doesn't
scale as well with Cloud tests the queue
xsa buffer where you can pause it or you
can queue higher priority tasks and
ensure that your bigquery rights are
identical
for any of your data processing pipeline
another way would yes a different
execution which is generally used to
offload heavyweight compute serverless
training and to defer the execution of a
large number of jobs in this scenario we
have an example of deferred jobs where
task queue are not used in front of the
application but we did it through
execution control putting things into
context you could be an online retail
store where what's your user shops
analytics drops on user clicks are being
queued to run stop level updates are
being added to a task queue to write to
Firestar and using Cloud functions as a
notification service to send follow-up
emails for the sales campaigns next
month these are just some example use
cases for you to try out today
on the other hand we have Cloud
scheduler which is our version of a
fully managed con job service
Cloud scheduler helps to trigger jobs
from batch jobs to Big Data and Cloud
operations you can configure your jobs
to retry in case of any failures or
errors a can set a maximum number of
free tries to add resiliency Cloud
scheduler also
lucky tries and execute a job in a fork
tolerant manner by deploying to
different digits so that you can
eliminate the risk of a single point of
failure as seen in traditional current
Services it also provides reliable
delivery with at least once delivery
guaranteed to your job targets similarly
it supports targets such as app engine
Cloud pops up and HTTP endpoints
allowing jobs to trigger to compute
engine Google's kubernetes engine and
on-premises resources it also uses the
standard authentication for you to
invoke your schedules in a secure
fashion
similarly card scheduler also uses
identity and access management for
Access Control Cloud scheduler also
publishes logs at the start and end of
each execution for you to look up the
actual execution times and check job
configurations you can also integrate
Cloud scheduler with VPC service
controls which currently support Cloud
Pub sub targets for you to set up a
secure parameter to guide against data
exploitation now let's dive into how
simple it is to set cut scheduler now
let's go through an example of setting
up Cloud scheduler when we head over to
the console you can type Cloud scheduler
in the search bar select it
create a job and we can Define the
schedule here you can go ahead to name
your job
select the region of your choice as well
as any descriptions necessary that you
might need as well as the frequency so
over here you will head to specify the
schedule in Chrome format say for
instance every Friday of the week at 9am
you need this job to run
as well as specifying
the time zone
you can go ahead to click continue
to configure the execution and the
target supported we have three types
which is HTTP pops up as well as engine
for the purpose of this demo we will be
using pops up targets we can go ahead
to specify the topic we want to trigger
the message as well as the message body
click continue and over here you can
configure optional settings such as
retry configs where you'll be able to
set the maximum retry attempts
duration or more of your choice like
what we have mentioned in the earlier
parts of the video and you can go ahead
to create this scheduler
upon creation it will bring you to this
panel here where you can observe and
manage your scheduled jobs for an
overview on when it was last run whether
the results has been successful or not
when it's the next run and under the
action to be able to force a job to run
as well as view locks like what we have
mentioned earlier and there you have it
it's simple to get started on cloud
scheduler some sample use cases include
scheduling database backups you can run
a cloud scheduler drop to periodically
trigger your database backup function on
an hourly basis to be SQL admin API the
database then generates the exports and
saves it to cloud storage having
database exports on cloud storage led to
create a robust Disaster Recovery plan
where you can export it to a different
region import it to other Cloud SQL
instances or other MySQL instances to
ensure a quick recovery into event of
any
another use case would be for data
injection you can set up Cloud scheduler
to trigger data through batch drops into
Bitcoin using the data flow templates we
have guided tutorials for you to follow
this architecture along as well
not forgetting here's an example that
describes the architecture for a
serverless Content render which is
commonly seen in social media and gaming
Industries these scenarios often involve
serving high volume of pre-structured
content where the data incorporates data
from external sources and that data can
be then processed or combined before
being incorporated into custom
structured content in this architecture
you can see how the high volume serving
path is highly decoupled from the
content preparation pipeline resulting
in cost efficiencies as well as greater
architectural resilience
moreover content forms can be based on
several variations such as user type
geographic location or queries of the
external data we can then use cloud
scheduler to schedule variations to
capture new data from external sources
as it updates content variations and
then schedule as tasks within Cloud
tasks itself
to capture content and schedule
rendering we can leverage Cloud run to
fetch the external data
which is then stored in some form of
intermediate storage such as data store
to allow multiple rendering variations
to consume data in the architecture
reducing redundant calls to the external
data store this processing of each data
fetch task results in multiple rendered
variations for each content type where
it's then scheduled as a further set of
tasks within Cloud tasks for the next
stage the content is eventually rendered
and stored in cloud storage itself where
it will then efficiently be served
through Cloud CDN to end user web and
mobile applications as shown in the
image a full write-up of this
architecture is available in our
architecture reference page for YouTube
deep dive into it as well and bringing
it back to how our customers are using
Cloud tasks and Cloud schedule today
previously in video 3 of our build
series we have covered how arabes AI
uses Cloud brand to reduce their server
costs additionally they were also able
to use cloud tasks and Cloud scheduler
for orchestration of their workflow and
only minimal effort is spent on
operations helping them to reduce costs
latency as well as improve productivity
with that I hope this video has deepened
your understanding of cloud task and
Cloud scheduler if you are interested to
find out more feel free to check out the
additional resources provided in the
descriptions below
and that marks the end of the segment of
the startup Journey with our Builder
series we have kicked out the series
with our large video startups programs
to firestore analytics with bigquery how
you can use spark and Hadoop with data
from streaming processing pipelines with
data film data visualization and data
Studio ml apis vertex AI API management
with Apache security deep dive and today
we have learned more on orchestrating
our workloads with Cloud task and Cloud
scheduler and that concludes the build
series we are excited to share more with
you in our next segment to grow series
to help startups that have launched on
Google Cloud to optimize and skill and
that's a wrap under build series don't
forget to like And subscribe on our
YouTube channel and click on the Bell
icon to get notified when our YouTube
begins thank you and we can't wait to
see you again
[Music]